Sam I wanted to start with you not just
as a screenwriter here but as the person
who wrote the original play is there
anything about revisiting your own
material but through the screenplay
format that made something in your
original play stronger than you ever
realized it was oh yeah I mean in many
different ways I mean you know I started
writing this play 13 years ago I I'm
kind of a different person and I'm also
a dad now to a five-year-old girl my
husband and I have our parents and so
like the condition of being a parent has
really shed a lot of light uh into
corners of the story that I didn't
really know were there uh and and then
also just like working with Brendan and
seeing the all of the beautiful depth of
humanity that he brought to it and his
kind of uncanny ability to hold Despair
and joy at the exact same moment taught
me a lot about the character too so
speaking of that to specify something
what would you say is the biggest
difference between the play and the
movie be for folks who haven't seen it
yeah yeah the the spine of the story is
pretty much identical I think probably
the largest change is the missionary
character played by times Ty Simpkins uh
in the play it's a Mormon missionary uh
and I think I probably did that in a bit
of an act of self-protection uh
self-protection because I uh I grew up
around a lot of Mormons but my
experience with religion was with a
fundamentalist church that's much more
similar to the one that he attends in
the screenplay Ty is incredible he
really is a movie I'm very glad he
jumped back into acting with this
particular production Brendan I caught a
quote from you that just really caught
my eye you said that the film demanded
that you combine everything you've
learned in your professional life and
this might be me trying to get too
specific with it but can you name a Past
film or show that you did that really
came in handy here that might surprise
people the only thing that I had to do
or required
effort physical effort I mean action
films and comedy sequences and stunts
and all of that that can be painted with
a pretty broad brush but it taught me
um to come from a place of uh just using
the body
Charlie needed to do a deadlift like an
Olympic Athlete every time he stood up
um and the the gear that I was wearing
the apparatus and the makeup while it
was cumbersome it was
it was necessary to
to to sell the gravity that um he would
have to live with and
um I know that probably in the movies
that I've made in that way in terms of
having a real objective to sell a
character's physicality in his body all
everything all those types of roles all
came into play when when we did Charlie
yeah wanted to talk a little bit about
your collaboration together on set
because I was reading that Sam you were
on set all the time which you know it's
a little unusual for for a screenwriter
to be that involved so what signaled to
you that you would best serve the
project if you were on set that in that
capacity and then Brendan what was it
about having Sam on set that really
influenced your performance for the
better I think I mean this is a pretty
unique situation in terms of
screenwriting given that like this is a
play that I wrote from a very personal
place and you know I followed this play
around in the first four Productions
doing rewrites and working very closely
with the cast and so you know it would
be I think a different situation if like
Darren thought of an idea for a story
and then hired somebody to execute it
for him
um so I just you know and in the moment
I arrived on said I was really just like
I'm just here to help I don't want to be
in anybody's way I just want to be a
resource for everybody and I hope I hope
that I was you were absolutely and
because we had three weeks to rehearse
this that's quite unheard of when making
a feature film so a24 was really
generous of that amount of time we day
one Darren declared us a theater company
and we took to the rehearsal space with
a taped out floor of the apartment a
one-to-one
um sizing and um
and we approached it as would his
production
when it was on stage we we learned how
to play the part before we actually got
to the build set because it would be
such tight conditions and you know at
films that's quite cluttered and
sometimes like a submarine crew really
we'd be on top of each other but we
already knew
what story was so by having Sam there it
was helpful to always have the writer
there to refer to to help explain the
history of of
um a line or or a a need that one
character might have that maybe worked
on stage but had to translate to the the
screen and
um he would would sometimes give us
maybe an additional line or reword it a
little bit
um it was immensely helpful and mentally
mentally helpful to have you there yeah
jumping into your own personal research
that you did for this
um so we get like the broad Strokes on
screen but is there anything you came
across in your research like a teeny
tiny small detail that we don't
necessarily see in the center of a frame
or hear about be a dialogue but you
still had to hold tight to it and we can
feel it in forming your performance now
yes we I worked with the Obesity Action
Coalition who were an online support
group for people who live with obesity
and those that I was in touch with gave
me
the most vulnerable and sincere
stories their testimonial really about
what their life was now as it was when
they were children and what their hopes
were these are people who were possibly
awaiting a bariatric procedure who had
had one at any rate they were people who
were in
um either had gone through a huge
transition or they were about to where
they're stuck somewhere in between and
for what I learned from them was we're
all just people at the end of the day we
all are and it's difficult to connect
with those that we love the most when we
are confronted by what Society does its
very best to dismiss them this is a
story that lets us look inside Charlie's
apartment it it opens the door and
invites Us in to see who he is and and
the challenges he has
um I felt that everything I learned by
that Consulting Nation definitely
informed who Charlie was so incredibly
in fact effective in that respect I have
one last quote that I wanted a reference
that I caught that you said it was such
an intensely personal journey and I came
out the other side transformed so how do
you think going forward that
transformation that you experienced is
going to influence the projects you take
from here on out in terms of you know
the stories that you feel passionate
about telling but also the types of
collaborators that you want to keep
working with the hope is that you'll
find material that's meaningful to not
only everyone creating it but your
audience too now that can be a big ask
sometimes when looking for something
interesting to do
I just know that I feel I have
um been changed in a sense that
I I really want to work on projects that
honestly I just I care more about I love
to make people laugh I love to have
something exciting or interesting or
Innovative happen when I work on a film
but if there's something there that can
speak to a broader common Humanity that
we all share I want to be a part of
something like that great success with
this one I can't wait to see more and
same for you Sam thank you so much for
your time today congratulations thanks
so much